oddly enough rats helped launch my own
writing as well they've been good to us
rats have been a good distance I think I
was a sophomore in high school
and I was kind of a nerdy kid that you
know I wasn't one of the cool kids I
wasn't good at sports good I was good at
you know on a roll and stuff that
doesn't cut in East any slacking in in
school that just gets you more abuse but
sophomore year my one of my English
teachers was teaching pose pit in a
pendulum and he said you know this story
has a terrible ending if you remember
that story the guys in the pit the
pendulums coming lower and lower and
then suddenly in the last paragraph
trumpet sound and the pendulum pulls up
and he saved the Inquisition is in the
hands of its enemies is the last thing
and and you know my English teacher said
this is a classic example of the deus ex
machina so our assignment was to write a
bitter ending for the bit oh boy
so I wrote an ending where the rats came
out and ate the guy and they ate is they
ate his cheeks and they ate his toes and
and you know they ate his face and the
pendulum cut him in half and he died
horribly screaming and in horrible pain
I thought it was a much better ending
than the one that at Yale and Polk came
up with it has a certain uplift to it I
feel it does but what was the real boost
for me is the teacher liked it too and
he had me read it to the class and
suddenly suddenly all these kids who'd
never thought much of me thought I was
the coolest kid in class man wow what a
great time what a great story the rats
ate the guy they loved it and I said why
I got a do more this writing stuff it's
really it's really pays off yeah yeah
that's pretty much my experience whether
they're two and you know one of the
things it's it's funny is we do this we
talk about these things and you guys are
laugh and applaud but later on you know
when you get home and you're in the dark
it's not gonna seem so funny then